de l'église la nuit dernière à la porte
de brandebourg à berlin pour célébrer la
nouvelle année
bonsoir permettez moi d'ouvrir cette
édition en vous présentant de la part de
toute l'équipe de la trois journalistes
et techniciens à paris en région
tous nos meilleurs voeux pour que cette
année 1990 soit heureuse et pleine de
santé pour chacun d'entre vous une année
1990 que nous allons débuter ensemble en
évoquant celle qui vient de se terminer
1989 placée sous le signe de la liberté
liberté conquise arraché parfois à l'est
le premier grand témoin de ce journal
sera piètre romane le nouveau premier
ministre roumain
il interviendra en direct de bucarest
qu'elle sera demain l'évolution des pays
de l'est notre deuxième invité sera
madame hélène carrère d'encausse 1989
c'est aussi un espoir de paix qui a
grandi sur les chemins politiques
difficiles du proche orient israël et la
palestine le liban déchiré par quinze
ans de guerre civile
autre grand témoin de cette édition
yasser arafat le président de l'ol paie
qui interviendra en direct de bagdad la
capitale de l'irak
et puis 1989 au moment où se préparer
les festivités du bicentenaire de la
révolution éclate et le printemps de
pékin en chine
les aspirations à la liberté et la
démocratie réprimé dans le sang
monsieur yan chaque qui étaient sur la
place tiananmen dans les premiers jours
de juin avant d'ouvrir cette grande page
spéciale nous allons faire le point de
l'actualité de ce 1er janvier
l'année débute par une nouvelle grande
catastrophe écologique
révélé il y a seulement 24 heures par le
maroc à 13 jours le pétrolier iranien se
situe alors à 200 km au large du maroc
depuis l'explosion la marée noire
s'étend et s'avance vers les côtes
marocaines seuls 20 kilomètres les
séparent ce soir sur place isabelle
mugler en survolant la zone cet après
midi nous avons constaté que le tanker
perdait encore du pétrole brut
les spécialistes à bord du navire
sinistrés n'ont donc pas pu colmater
entièrement les brèches du bateau
environ 70 milles tonnes de carburant se
sont déjà répandus en mer les soutes du
cargo contiennent encore près de 200000
vastes étendues noirâtre des nappes de
pétrole se sont formés sur une
superficie de 300 kilomètres carrés
environ
les vents et des courants marins font
dériver cette marée noire qui menace de
plus en plus le littoral marocain le
front de pollution se rapproche
dangereusement
il est à 20 km à peine du port doit
lydia l'un des plus grands parcs
ostréicoles du maroc
l'arrivée de la marée noire sur les
côtes constituerait le plus grand
désastre écologique que le pays ait
jamais connu une catastrophe économique
également qui supprimerait près de
100000 emplois dans le secteur maritime
principale préoccupation du gouvernement
marocain aujourd'hui stopper les nappes
de pétrole avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
mais le pays n'est ni les structures ni
les moyens de lutter efficacement contre
un tel fléau
l'appel à l'aide internationale lancé
par le maroc a été entendu accompagné
par brice lalonde le secrétaire d'état à
l'environnement
une mission d'experts français chargés
d'évaluer la situation est arrivée à
marrakech ce soir voici ce qu'il faut
encore retenir de l'actualité en france
et à l'étranger tout d'abord les
meilleurs voeux pour l'année 90 adressé
en choeur par le président des états
unis est le numéro un soviétique
rémy gullit shelly
je finis dans un grand élan mondialistes
pour développer les visées commun
diffusé ce soir à la même heure en urss
et aux états unis
pour george bush la décennie à venir
doit être celle du respect des droits de
l'homme mikhaïl gorbatchev est allé plus
loin en rejetant les conceptions
politiques et les doctrines militaires
fait rimer et en souhaitant la levée des
barrières artificielles entre les gens
et les états dix mille personnes
aujourd'hui dans les rues de hong kong
pour réclamer un avenir démocratique en
chine
les manifestants ont exprimé leur
crainte du communisme en célébrant les
bouleversements survenus en europe de
l'est au rang desquels la révolution
roumaine avait valeur de symbole la
situation pourrait évoluer rapidement au
panama où le général noriega a commencé
l'année dans les locaux de la nonciature
apostolique toujours cernée par les
troupes américaines
guillermo endara et le gouvernement
panaméen demanderont demain ou mercredi
au saint siège que noriega leur soient
livrés pour des raisons de sécurité le
président panaméen ne souhaite pourtant
pas que noriega soit incarcéré au panama
huit toiles du peintre henri matisse
dérobé vendredi soir dans cet
appartement inhabité appartenant à la
famille du maître sur les hauteurs de
nice
les cambrioleurs se sont emparés sans
difficultés de plusieurs originaux
estimé au total à plus de 75 millions de
francs
yasser arafat je vous le disais est en
direct de bagdad il est déjà au coeur de
l'actualité en 1990 une crise politique
ouverte en israël à propos de contact
entre le ministre travailliste et
service man et l'organisation de
libération de la palestine
ezer weizman a été a révoqué par le
premier ministre une décision qui doit
prendre effet demain et qui risque de
porter un coup fatal au fragile
gouvernement de coalition plus mauvais
rénale et gervais hitman au ministre
israélien de la science limogé par le
premier ministre itzhak shamir réserve
et hitman a reconnu ce soir s'est
entretenu récemment par téléphone avec
un haut responsable de l'olp et qui
pourrait être yasser arafat lui même
mais l'information n'a pu être confirmée
de sources palestiniennes je me suis
efforcé de convaincre mon interlocuteur
d'accepter le plan baker pour un
dialogue israélo-palestinien a expliqué
ezer weizman à l'issue d'une réunion cet
après midi avec les députés
travaillistes ses contacts n'avait rien
de secret plusieurs membres du
gouvernement étaient au courant
il n'empêche en tapant sur la table et
en prenant le risque d'une énième crise
gouvernementale le premier ministre
israélien itzhak shamir a d'abord tenu à
rappeler qu'il était le patron et qu'on
ne pouvait appartenir au gouvernement
israélien et négocier avec l'ol paie en
limogeant ezer weizman
ils traquent shamir met en porte à faux
les travaillistes membre de la coalition
gouvernementale qui officiellement
interdit tout contact avec l'ol paie les
travaillistes n'ont aucun intérêt
électoral à vouloir l'éclatement de la
coalition
les sondages ne leur sont pas favorables
mais en acceptant le limogeage des airs
weizmann
il conforte la position d'ytrac shamir
opposé à toute discussion avec l'ol paie
et ce à un moment crucial des
négociations avec les états unis
yasser arafat en direct de bagdad
monsieur arafat avez vous eu des
contacts au récemment avec monsieur
vietman alors apparemment je vois yasser
arafat joël hasard notre consoeur de
faire trois étapes
banana banana contact absolument aucun
contact entre nous et entraînera wiseman
la même par y voit la médaille ni de
près ni de loin
aucun de ces contacts ne s'est jamais
passé mais monsieur arafat négocier vous
actuellement avec israël et certains
membres du gouvernement
mais là chaque connaît la corse soit
arabe max heinzer comme doute il ya des
messagers qui bouge entre nous
assaillent haendel de contact avec les
israéliens y compris avec monsieur
shamir ce qui est sûr c'est envoyé
plusieurs lettres tandis que contact
direct il n'y en a absolument pas eu
absolument pas alors monsieur arafat on
se pose la question où en est le plan b
caire aujourd'hui 1990 saura-t-elle
l'année du tour de table et l'ouverture
en fin de négociation entre israël et
l'olp et la papda à sanaa je vous
apprends à lire comme al basri et à
travers le gouvernement égyptien
ça fait relativement tard l'ambassadeur
des etats-unis à tunis des messages que
le gouvernement égyptien est le
gouvernement américain on utilise ont
considéré comme raisonnable à la ja biya
mais en toute objectivité les records en
ce qui concerne la marche de la paix
c'est notre conduite
alors je vous le rappelle yasser arafat
grand témoin premier grand témoin de
cette édition sur la 3 édition consacrée
à la liberté
en 1989 une année cruciale dont nous
ouvrons tout de suite le grand livre et
nous marquons une première pause en
quatre volumes voici le premier qui
englobe les mois de janvier février mars
89 et tout d'abord c'est le départ de la
maison blanche de celui que l'on
surnomme le grand communicateur les
américains tourner une page
george bush un passionné de la pêche au
saumon arrive au pouvoir
jean-marc
le début de 89 et aussi pour l'amérique
la fin de huit ans de reaganisme avec
l'investiture de george bush
une année dont l'empereur hirohito ne
verra pas grand chose sa longue agonie
se termine enfin
plus d'un mois plus tard ses funérailles
donneront l'occasion aux grands de ce
monde de se rencontrer et de se
concerter en france pierre bérégovoy
relance la sphère pechiney des rumeurs
de délit d'initié plane sur max théret
et sur roger patrice pelât
l'opposition accuse à son tour les
entourages de bérégovoy d'être impliqués
dans des délits du même ordre au tour de
la société générale
les derniers soldats russes quittent
l'afghanistan le retrait des troupes
soviétiques est achevée au cours d'un
référendum sur la nouvelle constitution
les algériens disent oui à la fin du
monopole du fln et au début du
multipartisme
caracas s'embrase des émeutes de la faim
durement réprimés pour de nombreuses
victimes dans la capitale du venezuela
salman rushdie l'homme à abattre ces
versets sataniques attire la foudre de
khomeiny des milliers de fidèles sont
prêts à le tuer et le cri bien au
l'éducation nationale descendent dans la
rue son ministre lionel jospin promet
des revalorisations marée noire sur fond
blanc l'exxon valdez s'échoue en alaska
les fonctionnaires corses prennent le
mors aux dents ils réclament une prime
d'insularité lille est en état de siège
la victoire dans le tournoi des cinq
nations va cette année au quinze de
france 3 vainqueur aux municipales les
verts le ps mais aussi l'abstention
bernard blier n'empruntera plus l'entrée
des artistes
si vous prenez cette édition en cours je
vous rappelle que yasser arafat et le
premier grand témoin de cette édition
édition consacrée à l'année 1989 année
placée sous le signe de la liberté
monsieur rappaz qui est toujours en
direct de bagdad en irak
quel regard un peu moins d'un an après
l'affairé jeudi
quel regard portez-vous sur la montée
des intégrismes notamment aussi au sein
de l'ol paie
déçu a de son côté répété la question
votre ville basse oui monsieur rappaz je
vous demandais un peu moins d'un an
après laffaire rushdie quel regard
portez-vous sur la montée des
intégrismes et notamment au sein de
votre propre mouvement l'organisation de
libération de la palestine
mais ce sujet martin il ya dans m nos
organisations
nous avons toutes confessions nous avons
eu tellement de travail à l'intérieur au
sein de l'ol tu es d'accord vanilla
l'union nationale des amis et le
dénominateur commun les demandes rim at
elle fait destiné à brad de nos trois
organisations palestiniennes
indépendamment de la religion
wakanim à tous nationalistes
le dénominateur commun et la palestine
cette pureté et la garantie de la
démocratie au sein de l'ump
vous condamnez l'intégrisme partout
ailleurs dans le monde et notamment dans
certains pays proche du au proche orient
marc knobel à utah bros nous sommes
contre tout fanatisme isaca ne sont pas
contre tous les fanatismes quelques
soins les acca n'a pas paru il ya pire
que ce soit un extrémiste de gauche
aillent dès lors que ce soit un
extrémisme idéologique à ma porte et là
qui est comme à vélizy croyons à leurs
plus hauts pluralisme nous croyons à la
démocratie dans l'intérieur de notre
organisation palestinienne sur la scène
palestinienne
vous restez en direct à bagdad le grand
livre de l'année 89 suite nous
feuilletons maintenant les mois d'avril
mai et juin collection rédigé et dirigé
ce soir par jean marc pitte a
ce qui aurait dû être un simple match de
foot tourne au massacre en 95 supporters
de liverpool sont étouffés dans le stade
de sheffield charles vanel le doyen du
cinéma français quitte la scène
il avait 96 ans et plus de 200 films à
son actif les nombreuses fraudes qui ont
entaché des élections présidentielle et
législatives au panama pousse
l'opposition à descendre dans la rue
mais l'armée les sbires de noriega
ramène rapidement leur ordre dans le
sang l'assassinât de jean marie tjibaou
et de yeiwéné yeiwéné par l'un de leurs
compagnons d'armes frappe comme une
bombe la nouvelle calédonie on craint
une remise en cause du rétablissement de
la paix civile sur le caillou paul
toungui et d'arrêter c'est la fin d'une
cavale de plus de 40 ans pour l'ancien
chef de la milice lyonnaise la
révolution islamique a perdu son guide
mais l'ayatollah khomeini frappe encore
après sa mort puisque des dizaines de
fidèles sont victimes de l'hystérie
collective provoquée par ses obsèques le
petit chang et son jeu facétieux ont
séduit le public de roland garros
et pour parfaire son entrée dans la cour
des grands il remporte le tournoi contre
hedberg
l'abstention est une fois de plus la
vedette des élections européennes
par ailleurs les socialistes progressent
et les verts perce le français le plus
célèbre à l'étranger est enfin prophète
en son pays où ce taux passe du grand
bleu à l'habit vert et devient immortel
le printemps 1989 c'est l'espace de
quelques jours pékin en fleurs la chine
qui s'éveille à la liberté mais c'est
très vite aussi pékin ampleur avec la
répression sanglante sur la place
tiananmen
une répression qui a fait plusieurs
milliers de victimes ce sont là encore
les jeunes les étudiants qui ont conduit
ce mouvement de protestation pour plus
de démocratie
peu à peu les ouvriers les
fonctionnaires ont répondu à leur appel
et pour étouffer cette immense
enthousiasme les autorités chinoises ont
fait intervenir l'armée et ses chars
laurence wittner
c'est très certainement cette image que
l'histoire retiendra de la révolution
chinoise déjà écrasés mais pas
totalement vaincu
quand il lui reste encore le courage que
donne le désespoir place tiananmen quand
on y croyait encore 3000 étudiants
soutenus par des manifestations
quotidiennes de deux à trois cents mille
personnes choisissent la grève de la
faim pour lancer un énorme défi au
pouvoir communiste
au nom des réformes et de la démocratie
même la visite de mikhaïl gorbatchev une
visite pourtant historique après trente
ans de brouille sino soviétique passera
au second plan de l'actualité dans
bakchich partie le pouvoir ne peut plus
cacher son désarroi
si là aussi yang secrétaire général du
parti fait un pas vers les étudiants les
autres dirigeants semblent avoir disparu
et le mouvement de contestation toujours
pacifiques et désarmés s'étend vers la
province
lentement trop lentement peut-être
car la vieille garde du régime obtient
le soutien de l'armée à eauze yang
limoger le premier ministre li peng
reparaît à la télévision la ligne dure à
gagner
les chars ont envahi la place tiananmen
en pleine nuit la répression fera sans
pitié la communauté internationale
s'indigne mais se contente de faire
évacuer ses ressortissants
à l'heure de la normalisation les
manifestants sont devenus des rebelles
contre soit révolutionnaire ils seront
des milliers à être dénoncés condamnés
par des tribunaux d'exception exécuter
la chape de plomb est retombé sur la
chine
les campus sont bâillonnés la place
tiananmen nettoyer le printemps de pékin
est terminée
oui
notre invité yann piat çi président de
la fédération pour la démocratie en
chine
quel souvenir qu'elle avez vous conservé
de cette révolution - qui est renvoyée
note ces images que vous venez de voir
et il y en a de partout ça s'est fait en
australie en belgique au canada
mitsubishi cc pasly signé avec ceux qui
le critiquent aux danses latines gotoda
sega ne souffre à ces garçons paula
zoega alors j'ai des problèmes en de
retour sont en plateau avec les
traducteurs que ce soit depuis bagdad où
depuis ici même le plateau traducteur
chinois j'espère que tout se passe bien
chez vous aujourd'hui à hong kong
monsieur monsieur yan catchy aujourd'hui
on compte près de dix mille personnes
ont manifesté en faveur la démocratie en
chine
peut-il y avoir dans votre pays la chine
un processus identique à celui de la
roumanie
il voulait répéter la question s'il vous
plaît peut-il y avoir un processus
identique en chine à celui qui s'est
déroulé en roumanie clos magna
non donc à découvrir économique arabe ça
m'étonne pas mais il faut savoir que la
chine ne le supporte plus le régime sous
lequel ils vivent et que la démo les
manifestations on a dû en cause montre
que vous avez clairement et je crois que
on va voir réapparaître chien une
nouvelle vague de protestations alors il
ya deux possibilités la première c'est
que les hommes au pouvoir
lorsqu'ils sont confrontés au pouvoir
seront renversé par un coup d'état et il
se peut alors que les violences
surviennent en chine comme ça s'est
produit en chine comme ça c'est produit
rooney n'est pas vraiment merci l'autre
grand thème de cette édition petr romane
le premier ministre de la roumanie il
est en direct de bucarest j'espère qu'on
peut me le confirmer en régie monsieur
romain de vous m'entendez
elle prendra nouveau premier ministre
somalien en direct bucarest une édition
difficile que nous réalisons ce soir en
direct à bagdad avec yasser arafat
monsieur romane vous m'entendez merci
d'avoir choisi la croix pour votre
première dans l'intervention publique
comment avez vous vécu il ya sept mois
cette tentative de révolution en chine
monsieur monsieur royal est ce que vous
m'entendez je voudrais le puits par eric
cachard de la liaison était ami avec
bucarest apparemment pas pour l'instant
l'édition spéciale de la iii consacré à
1989 allées de la liberté nous
retournerons à bucarest dans quelques
instants nous allons d'abord évoqué une
autre grande page de la vie 1989 mais
pas les malins
wen juillet août septembre et tout
d'abord ce massacre dans un village près
de besançon
un homme tire sur tout ce qui bouge en
gros folie meurtrière à lux yole
christian dorny abattre 14 personnes
avec sa carabine avant d'être arrêté
dans sa course démente sécheresse 510
orages l'été 89 s'avère être l'été de
tous les dangers
5000 hectares brûlés lacanau la corse et
le sud-est seront touchées à leur tour
quelques jours plus tard 1v 2d près
laurent fignon perd le tour de france
vainqueur l'américain greg lemond
il était retenu en otage au liban depuis
février 88 sépare cassette vidéo
interposée pour en apprendre à la mort
du colonel
higgins fendue par ses ravisseurs
polémique autour du carmel d'auschwitz
les accords prévoyant le transfert des
religieuses installé aux portes de
l'ancien camp de concentration ne sont
pas respectées s'ensuit la crise la plus
grave entre communautés juives et
catholiques est depuis la fin de la
guerre livre enfin nouveau leader le 17
août le président rafsandjani prête
serment
mais ouvriers de peugeot mulhouse puis
de sochaux entament une grève
le bras de fer entre jacques calvet ses
salariés durera plus de six semaines la
guadeloupe panse ses plaies le cyclone
hugo laisse derrière lui cinq morts et
30 mille sans abri 171 personnes meurent
dans l'attentât du dc-10 d'uta reliant
brazzaville à paris et terroristes ne
sont pas identifiés les surveillants de
prison dépose les clés c'est l'armée qui
assure le fonctionnement des
établissements pénitentiaires
alors la pendaison du colonel d'higgins
abbey road c'est un épisode meurtrier
parmi tant d'autres dans l'histoire de
l'année 1989 au liban le proche orient
avec lui en 1989 entre les espoirs de
paix et les feux sans cesse rallumer de
la guerre
189 c'est encore et toujours la guerre
des pierres dans les territoires occupés
par israël le liban de 1989 ce sont 1000
morts des milliers de blessés au cours
des affrontements très violents entre
chrétiens et musulmans
le liban s'est aussi l'assassinât d'un
homme d'un président jean-paul girouard
l'année loire du liban commence le 14
mars
ce jour là le général aoun déclare la
guerre de libération nationale contre
l'occupant syrien
le déluge de feu commence pendant six
mois vers ou depuis le tiers du pays
résonne du bruit des obus la communauté
internationale finit par s'émouvoir du
massacre le 26 mai un triumvirat est
mise en place par la ligue arabe pour
trouver une solution
il faudra trois mois à l'arabie saoudite
à l'algérie et au maroc pour parvenir à
un cessez le feu
le 23 septembre l'accord de taef signer
immédiatement après et l'élection d'un
nouveau président rené mouawad suscite
un bref espoir très bref 17 jours après
son élection
rené moawad et tué dans un attentat à la
bombe
élias hraoui lui succède mais au lieu de
l'espoir c'est un statu quo précaires
qui s'installe
michel aoun ne reconnaît pas élias
hraoui comme légitime
il récuse les accords de taille sans
aucun soutien international michel aoun
tient toujours dans son palais de baabda
grâce à la ferveur de ses partisans en
90 tout est possible le meilleur ou de
nouveau le pire intifada la guerre des
pierres
l'archaïsme de larmes employés n'empêche
pas cette guerre d'usure d'être
sanglante meurtrière au quotidien face
aux palestiniens de l'intérieur l'armée
israélienne tire le 9 décembre dernier
c'était le deuxième anniversaire du
soulèvement l'occasion de quelques
statistiques lugubre 613 palestinien tué
soixante dix mille blessés parmi les
morts 131 enfants de moins de 16 ans du
côté israélien
dix neuf tués 2400 blessés malgré son
enlisement sur le terrain l'intifada a
tout de même relancer l'intérêt
diplomatique pour la question
palestinienne
d'intenses négociations ont lieu entre
les états unis l'ol paie et israël
1 / de manière séparée it right shamir
refuse toujours de s'asseoir à la même
table que yasser arafat pourtant le
leader de l'olp et a multiplié les
concessions de façade en particulier par
l'emploi du terme qu'a dû pour désigner
la charte de l'ol paie en attendant dans
les territoires occupés c'est la routine
intifada était une explosion de colère
elle est devenue cette année un mode de
vie et de mort yasser arafat toujours en
direct de bagdad à propos de lentilles
fada et des territoires occupés va-t-on
assister en 1990 a peut-être permanence
de la violence ou va-t-on enfin
s'installer autour d'une table et tenter
de renouer le dialogue
nous sommes pour que l'année 90 soit
l'année du dialogue de conférence
internationale sur les espèces des
nations unies avec la participation des
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité et avec la participation de
toutes les parties du conflit y compris
le lt et le gouvernement israélien
malheureusement et shamir essaie
d'empêcher des israéliens de travailler
avec nous pour construire la paix tandis
que nous optimiserons à travailler avec
tous ceux qui veulent construire la paix
pour bâtir la vraie paix sur la terre de
la paix la palestine ce moment où les
chiffres des martyrs et des blessés
augmente et en nous entendons des
chiffres mais il y en a plus il y à plus
de mille martyrs et à plus de 350 mille
blessés et plus de soixante quatorze
mille blessés et 6500 handicapés 5200
avortement entre les femmes entre nos
femmes nous demandons à toute l'opinion
mondiale est précisément l'opinion
européenne qui ne se tiennent aux côtés
du peuple palestinien et
aux côtés des droits des citoyens et de
l'homme palestiniens comme il l'a fait
ailleurs dans le monde
mais précisément en europe notamment en
europe
monsieur en femme est spécialement que
ce qui se passe au moment où le l'europe
s'ouvre entièrement est précisément de
rock petit peu leste sur la liberté nous
voyons shamir et des soldats de shamir
les armes de shamir s'ériger pour
empêcher et priver le peuple palestinien
de la liberté de l'autodétermination et
empêchait aussi le fait que les
palestiniens d'établir son état
à l'instar de tous les autres peuples et
de toutes les autres nations du monde
tout ce que nous demandons c'est la
légalité et de légitimité mondiale
monsieur arafat vous restez toujours en
direct avec nous à bagdad l'année 1989
placée sous le signe de la liberté c'est
le thème de cette édition spéciale
dernier chapitre maintenant du grand
livre de l'année 1989 les mois d'octobre
novembre et décembre dominée par la
sacralisation du dalaï lama dernières
pages feuilletées par anne gouraud
le dalaï lama chef spirituel de la
communauté tibétaine reçoit le prix
nobel de la paix est un camouflet pour
la chine qui exprime son indignation
extrême
après 25 ans de prison en afrique du sud
ou alter sisulu et sept membres de l'
insee sont enfin libérés
san francisco tremble un séisme de cette
bévue la secoue la région faisant 72
morts la plupart sont les automobilistes
victimes de l'effondrement d'un électron
après cinq mois de conflit la grève des
impôts et des douanes perdre son ampleur
reprise également du travail dans les
usines ce jour de mulhouse et de sochaux
en refusant d'enlever leur foulard au
nom de leur religion
fatima léila et samira provoque un
véritable débat de fond sur la laïcité
la tolérance et l'intégration la sphère
de creil enflamme la france et sera
porté devant le conseil d'état
c'est la fin de renault billancourt l'
usine fermera ses portes définitivement
en 1992 premier saut les bouches
gorbatchev à malte à l'ordre du jour le
désarmement et de grands parle de
réduction des arsenaux stratégiques et
d'acteurs alliance atlantique pacte de
varsovie le monde entier pleure celui
qui fut le symbole de la dissidence et
des droits de l'homme andreï sakharov
physicien prix nobel de la paix nord le
14 décembre au panama le général manuel
noriega et chapeau 26 mille soldats
américains
recherché pour trafic de drogue noriega
se réfugie à la nonciature apostolique
le soir de noël
trois derniers mois de l'année en
portait bien sûr par le souffle de la
liberté dans la quasi totalité de
l'europe de l'est ce sont les effets
dévastateurs de la pérestroïka la
hongrie la pologne la rda la
tchécoslovaquie la bulgarie enfin à la
roumanie
on peut parler d'une véritable contagion
l'histoire est allé très très vite
alès fini pisteurs frontière
austro-hongroise le 2 mai un petit coup
de cisaille pour une première grande
brèche dans le rideau de fer 24 août
tadeusz mazowiecki premier non
communiste nommé à la tête d'un
gouvernement d'un pays du bloc de l'est
ce le résultat de dix ans de lutte et
polonais pionniers c'est peut-être à
l'étincelle polonaise que l'on doit à
l'embrasement 7 octobre pour la première
fois un partout que lenny ski de l'est
souche aborde le parti socialiste
ouvrier hongrois se transforme en parti
socialiste hongrois tout court 9
novembre le mur de berlin sont en éclats
ouverture des frontières entre les deux
allemagnes 3 millions d'allemands de
l'est vont faire un petit tour à l'ouest
un mur qui a cédé sous la terrible
pression de la rue et de l'exode à
travers la brèche hongroise
le lendemain pétards mladenov remplace
l'inamovible todor jivkov au pouvoir
depuis 54 la bulgarie se laisse séduire
par les sirènes de la part historique à
24 la contagion gagne la tchécoslovaquie
la direction du pc démissionnent en bloc
le faire du fond de prague alexandre do
check réapparait au devant de la scène
28 le régime 7 sur toute la ligne
renonce au rôle dirigeant du parti
accepte le principe du multipartisme 1er
décembre le pcast allemand copie d'une
seule voix il renonce lui aussi à son
rôle dirigeant
un catcheur c'est enfin de tourner la
roumanie la révolution par de timisoara
le vin de chez ocz escou tente de
s'enfuir
le jour de noël les juges ne lui fera
pas de cadeau
d'abord vendredi 29 décembre l'ancien
prisonnier entre château vaclav havel
élu chef de l'état tchécoslovaque un sac
pour la revanche du printemps
nous avons à l'instant établi la liaison
avec la roumanie avec bucarest monsieur
rome un nouveau premier ministre aux
roumains en direct de bucarest est ce
que vous m'entendez cette fois monsieur
romane vous m'entendez monsieur roma
nous voyons vous êtes en direct à
bucarest édition difficile je vous le
disais avec des directs à bagdad qui ont
fonctionné jusqu'à maintenant monsieur
romane
est-ce que vous m'entendez dernière
tentative sinon nous reviendrons à
bucarest dans quelques minutes car nous
avons bien sûr beaucoup de questions à
vous poser notamment sur les trois
dernières mesures prises par votre
gouvernement a annoncé hier soir
l'abolition de la peine de mort le
retour à la semaine de cinq jours
et puis surtout la redistribution des
terres il y avait été collective nation
en valais ce que vous entendez la
tentative qui est un échec café du matin
nous revenons maintenant sur les
bouleversements dans les pays laisse
nous en parlons bordas l'instant avec
notre invité hélène carrère d'encausse
et tout de suite
retour sur la question allemande sur la
rd à la chute du mur de berlin
précisément alors sur toutes les bouches
ce mot la réunification alors évidemment
le rapprochement des deux allemagnes
suscite un débat dans le monde entier
cela va bouleverser la construction
européenne n risacher
metz et l'ouest réunis la nuit dernière
à berlin les allemands des deux côtés
ont fêté ensemble la nouvelle année ce
réveillon du siècle comme il l'appelle
inimaginable il ya seulement deux mois
jusqu'à cette nuit du 9 novembre dernier
premier coup de pioche contre le mur de
la honte qui divise berlin depuis 28 ans
les frontières s'ouvrent des dizaines de
milliers d'allemands de l'est se rendre
à l'ouest pour la première fois se
promener faire des achats voir leur
famille vu que ce 28 novembre
coup de théâtre à beaune cette fois le
chancelier ouest allemand helmut kohl
dévoile son plan de restauration de
l'unité allemande
avec dans un premier temps des structure
confédérale entre la rfa et la rda
helmut kohl n'a prévenu personne il
surprend le monde entier et son plan est
accueillie avec une relative réserve car
le spectre du troisième reich existe
encore dans les consciences aller le
débat sur la réunification a commencé
huit jours auparavant dans les rues de
leipzig où les manifestants réclament à
une folk ein reich ein landes un peuple
un état un pays mais le slogan est loin
de faire l'unanimité dans l'opposition
des réticences apparaissent et les
autorités réformatrice est allemandes
disent pas question de brader la rda à
la réforme adrese le 19 décembre premier
sommet interallemande hans modrow le
premier ministre de l'est et helmut kohl
chancelier de l'ouest planifient la
communauté contractuels qui sera mise en
place entre les deux allemagne cette
année
dans le même temps helmut kohl cherche à
rassurer ses partenaires européens
inquiets de voir une grande allemagne
faire sécession
cole réaffirmé l'ancrage ouest allemand
dans la communauté des 12 mai les
dirigeants des douze doivent aussi être
réaliste l'unité de la nation allemande
se fera si les allemands le veulent tel
est le message de françois mitterrand
alors président de la communauté
européenne en visite le 21 décembre à
berlin est et le lendemain la célèbre
porte de brandebourg symbole de la
division des deux allemagnes la porte
est ouverte
alors notre invité sur les voleurs se
ment dans les pays de l'est madame
hélène carrère d'encausse on ne vous
présente plus vous êtes écrivain vous
êtes historienne le point de départ de
l'ensemble de ce phénomène
révolutionnaire dans toute l'europe de
l'est
c'est l'union soviétique d'après vous
sans aucun doute et c'est ce qui s'est
passé tout m en union soviétique au
début de cette année les élections qui
ont eu lieu au printemps et qui ont mis
en place un parlement à début de
parlements ou sous les yeux de toute
l'union soviétique il ya eu un déballage
extraordinaire télévisée toute la
journée et tous les soviétiques étaient
devant leur téléviseur ou laisser
parlementaires élus et qui ont été élus
souvent au détriment du parti communiste
dire que le parti communiste a tremblé
sur ses bases et on a appris en union
soviétique qu'être membre du parti
communiste n'était plus un gage de
réussite électorale
ça devait des idées à tout le monde
savait quand on est c'est la fin d'une
primauté du parti communiste et c'est là
que se pose le problème d'un parti
communiste qui conserve son rôle
dirigeant alors qu'électoralement il est
extrêmement ébranlé
alors quel est d'après vous dans
l'ensemble de l'europe de l'est le
visage du communisme qui se cache
derrière l'ensemble des gouvernements de
coalition qui ont lui jouera je dirais
que visage du communisme est très ambigu
d'une certaine façon c'est gouvernement
de coalition ressemble à ce qu'on a vu
il ya 45 ans ou des partis communistes
minoritaires ont tiré les ficelles ont
été placés dans des gouvernements de
coalition et on tire les ficelles
jusqu'au moment où ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir ça c'est l'apparence mais la
réalité c'est celle de 1990 c'est à dire
que le communisme
à 45 ans durant montré son incapacité à
assurer tout simplement là une vie
décente aux hommes et une vie de liberté
il est complètement discrédité ces
partis sont non seulement sur la
défensive mais ils sont dans beaucoup de
cas comme en pologne porté à bout de
bras par la coalition tout simplement
pour qu'ils ne s'effondrent pas trop
vite pour qu'il n'y ait pas une
catastrophe très rapide c'est au chiffre
qu'en roumanie au four solaire
le parti les communistes qui sont là ne
sont plus là en tant que communiste
mais en tant que cadre encore existants
madame carrère d'encausse je vous
interromps nous avons enfin la liaison
avec bucarest monsieur romain est ce que
vous m'entendez monsieur romane nouveau
premier ministre roumain merci d'être le
grand témoin de cette édition nous avons
eu beaucoup de mal à vous joindre mais
cette fois tout marche
votre gouvernement a adopté trois
mesures hier soir l'abolition de la
peine de
or le retour à la semaine de cinq jours
et surtout la redistribution des terres
à l'ensemble de la paysannerie roumaine
c'est un premier pas vers une économie
de marché je suis et de la basse avec
les communes et on sait ça se passe et
messieurs je suis pas de problème de
fabien informé puisque ce n'est pas
comme ça je vais être intégrée ce que
j'aime ma campagne lecteurs je croyais
mais indirectes pour la télévision
française où nous ne sommes pas
responsables de ce qui vous a été dit
monsieur romane concernant michel rocard
ou lionel jospin
nous n'avons pas la responsabilité
deuxième point votre démocratie encore
tout jeune et j'allais dire balbutiante
fait que votre intervention est
retransmise de sa propre initiative par
la télévision roumaine nous n'avons pas
d'accord particulier avec elle il était
bon le préciser je reviens à ma question
sur la redistribution des terres vous
êtes prêt à engager la roumanie vers une
économie de marché
pour l'instant le plaza d'assumer une
tâche d'une importance aussi
considérable vous jugez un peu non
mesure sur le plan économique avec aussi
la neutralisation qui a poussé le centre
et dans mes rapports cette intention de
marcher planification
n'oubliez pas que notre tâche les
provisoire puisque provisoire est très
bientôt à monsieur val je sais que vous
avez leçon j'espère que vous avez
également les images en provenance de
france cela nous avait été assuré vous
allez entendre un document exceptionnel
récupéré par notre envoyé spécial jean
françois grégoire qui se trouve
actuellement en roumanie un film
d'amateur tourner le 22 décembre
la première réunion du comité national
de salut public qui laisse penser que
tout était prêt en roumanie pour
renverser nicolae ceaucescu depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà au palais
présidentiel la confusion est totale via
les scoops et romane viennent de
s'adresser à la foule
ils veulent maintenant rédiger le
premier communiqué du front de salut
national
à l'intérieur du palais de nombreuses
personnes accusent y ait secoué son
groupe de vouloir récupérer le mouvement
pour calmer les esprits lyonniais secoue
accepte qu'une caméra puisse filmer
cette première séance de travail à ce
moment là la tension est extrême
on tire dans les sous-sols du palais ses
futurs membres du gouvernement vont
complètement oublier la caméra bhl
mais je ne sais pas comment il fait là
commentaire c'est ça parce que là j'ai
njawe a une assise ne peut pas venir
alors nous sommes foutus mais le hic
c'est amour en fait il connaît certaines
choses il sépare on entrait déjà les
premiers propos tenus mystérieux jette
un certain trouble
mais quelques minutes plus tard une
discussion entre lyonniais spoof futur
président du front du sel nationale
pétré romane futur premier ministre et
le général luis lietaer futur ministre
de la défense
cette discussion révèle que la création
du front de salut national ne relevait
surtout pas de la provocation salue ce
n'est pas bien de l'état démocratie
nation serait mieux yoni et secours
excusez moi mais la démocratie on a déjà
parlé un peu partout dans le monde m
robin baitz à lui qu'est ce que c'est
l'avenir
moi quand j'ai parlé à la télévision
j'avais dit le fond d'unité populaire
général militare le front de salut
national fonctionne depuis six mois ce
document est donc une preuve formelle
le front de salut national n'a pas été
créée le 22 décembre 89
il existait donc depuis un certain temps
en roumanie un groupe de personnes à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de la
l'état qui prépare l après ceausescu
témoin cette apparition incroyable en
pleine réunion de hauts responsables de
la chicorée tâte art délai à nous chefs
de la défunte brigade anti-terroriste
dépendant de la division 5 la plus
redoutable un coup d'état aurait même
été initialement prévu le 24 décembre
mais les événements de timisoara ont
obligé le front de salut national a
précipité les choses
ce comité clandestins il ya encore deux
semaines s'est donc retrouvé plus tôt
que prévu à la tête de la roumanie
monsieur romane vous m'entendez toujours
en direct à bucarest
première question pourquoi voit-on le
chef de la brigade antiterroriste à
cette réunion labeur n'est pas assez
mais pas du tout correct quand ont été
prises ces images
ce n'est pas du tout avec de magnifiques
images tournées le 22 décembre tournée
par un journaliste amateur nous l'avons
dit les images ont été prises dans
différents endroits en face à montaut
locaux d'abord médias des images comme
celles-là s'est ouvert lundi à la
libération et déjà tous passionnés minsk
où l'alimentation jusqu'où donc je
répète nous il est dans no 6 du combiné
à la mouvance d'une conductrice travel
acceptant le soir souvent je veux dire
c'est beau c'est c'est eh bien après que
changer ce projet est parti éliminé par
la révolution parce que je savais mais
vous lire on ne sait pas ce que j'ai
souhaité limiter sa hausse est attendue
le 22 décembre examinaient des
animateurs
c'est ce que souhaitent les j étais là
ses empreintes sur oman dès maintenant
vous attendriez deuxièmement non
deuxième trimestre
dans la nuit du siège de la télévision
ce alors que cela ne prouve rien pas ma
soeur mais non mais non pas l'un des
personnalités que nous voyons sur ces
images ça commence à voir des attentions
et leurs saveurs à toutes les
personnalités qui se trouvent encore
nationale personnalité et sur sa part un
siège du comité central avait deux ans
avec nous c'est clair
question monsieur romane avez-vous était
devancé par les événements de timisoara
y avait-il un comité national de salut
public avant la chute du dictateur dans
votre pays et aviez vous des contacts au
préalable avec les responsables de la
securitate
il a eu deux organisations nationales et
c'est pour ça que nous avons toujours
une secousse n'a eu que nous nous soyons
si vous voulez le front de la vague
qu'elle était maintenue la mission pour
aider le laisser si vous voulez
l'utiliser
ce sont des spéculations monsieur romane
afin je les dires de tempérer un petit
peu ce qui pourrait être certains
malentendus
je voudrais vous demander de regarder
cet homme c'est en quelque sorte le
cadeau du 19/20 à la fin de cette
édition
avez vous le souvenir de cet homme et
reconnaissez-vous savoie bon ben on
jouait peu
comment vas tu je vais bien et je joue
il a compris que les choses se sont
passées comme tel pouvez vous monsieur
romande pouvez vous dire à l'ensemble
des téléspectateurs français qui est
monsieur lucien max bernat et pourquoi
vous est si content de le voir
aujourd'hui je vous le dis tout de suite
cette professeure à l'école icloud
informatique sable j'espère maintenant
qu'il est directeur de l'institut de
mécanique vie de tous ces faits j'espère
que c'est mon père s'appelle c'est un
très grand ami a alors fait je voudrais
te dire combien on a été fier et a même
pas inquiet de te voir associé à à ce
niveau de responsabilité et à ce
renouveau de la roumanie alors tous tes
amis toulousains tout ce que tu as vu
encore lors de tes récent passage te
font en grandement de confiance en toi
autant détermination dans le
développement de la démocratie dans ton
pays et je voulais te dire combien
combien on est on a on pense que tu
mettras tout comme l'intelligence tous
tes capacités de travail à cette tâche
exige un niveau je voudrais aussi
ajouter d'autres mots on a eu beaucoup
de mal à développer les échanges entre
nos deux instituts pendant les dernières
années pour des raisons que l'on connaît
bien et j'espère que c'est une nouvelle
ère des échanges culturels entre nos
deux pays et en particulier et bien sûr
sur la discipline qui nous est cher sur
les
la physique des fluides les problèmes
d'environnement et ce journal tout
allait recommencer avec le problème du
maroc
il se trouve que petr roman n'a
travaillé sur les problèmes d'interface
et il doit se sentir aujourd'hui
fortement concerné par les questions
d'environnement
merci monsieur max bernat monsieur
romane merci d'avoir été l'invité de
cette édition est d'avoir répondu avec
franchise clarté à l'ensemble de nos
questions nous allons maintenant en
direct à bagdad rejoindre monsieur
yasser arafat
l'autre grand témoin de cette édition
monsieur arafat est ce que vous
m'entendez est-ce que nous avons la
liaison avec bagdad
je pose la question à la régie tout a
bien fonctionné jusqu'à maintenant je
suis sûr que cela va marcher encore
monsieur arafat nous venons d'avoir
monsieur romane en direct à la
télévision depuis française depuis
bucarest
nous revenons donc sur les événements
qui se sont déroulés ces dernières
semaines en roumanie
on l'a dit et répété qu'il y avait des
soldats palestinien aux côtés de la
securitate à bucarest démentez vous
confirmez vous cette information
malheureux de voir répéter de telles
rumeurs encore une fois bien que les
responsables de roumains ont affirmé que
ceci est dénuée de tout fondement et
surtout après denik nous avons émis je
trouve bizarre que de telles rumeurs
soient encore été tirées par le maréchal
roumanie alors que nous sommes liés par
le peuple avec le peuple roumain par des
relations solides dont le avec lesquels
nous sommes fiers monsieur arafat à
propos des liens avec la roumanie on a
beaucoup parlé également de vos liens
avec monsieur sait où c'est ce coup vous
étiez présent au dernier congrès du
parti communiste roumain à bucarest
est ce que monsieur c ou c ce coût était
de fait l'intermédiaire des relations
entre l'israël l olp
non nous en parle et depuis que j'écris
la connaissance du président tchétchène
sco lorsqu'il faisait l'intermédiaire
entre le président sadate et begin ce
qui était connu
il était l'un des chefs qui est ferré
les intermédiaires dans le traité de
camp david ce rôle a s'est poursuivie un
rôle de ceausescu
dans une tentative d'établir des
rencontres palestino israéliennes et
n'oubliez pas que le président cherchait
ce qu avait été à vocation et à date
comme l'a reconnu la frappe et reste
avec les responsables israéliens des
relations solides et bien connu et bien
établi et premiers contacts qu'il a eus
entre nous et le groupe avant un an et
demi à peu près cela s'est passé à
bucarest
merci monsieur rafat d'avoir accepté
d'être le grand témoin de cette édition
l'année 1989 placée sous le thème de la
liberté
yasser arafat en direct de bagdad pietro
romane en direct de bucarest
merci d'être resté fidèle au 19/20
poursuivre cette édition pendant une
heure à demain 19h tout de suite la
météo de michel tour est très bonne
soirée à tous
m
et
ah bon